ينتهي خط السكك الحديدية من أوكرانيا عند
المنصة الخامسة في محطة القطار في
شوماشيل بولندا بعد أن خرج اللاجئون
من هذا القطار نفسه وسيعودون
لأسابيع ، وكان معظمهم من الرجال العائدين
للانضمام إلى القتال الأوكراني ضد
روسيا ولكن أمام قطار قراءة
اللافتة لأوكرانيا
تنتظر النساء ساعات للعودة
إلى منطقة الحرب
بالقرب من مقدمة الخط ، وجدنا
تاتيانا فيرمشينكو ، لقد أتت إلى بولندا
منذ ثلاثة أيام لإحضار
ابنتيها البالغتين إلى بر الأمان الآن ، والآن
ذاهب إلى منزله في بلدة في شرق البلاد.
أوكرانيا بالقرب من الحدود الروسية ،
أوكرانيا لها نفس القدر من الأهمية للرجال
والنساء ، وتقول إننا النساء الأوكرانيات الحقيقيات
لديهن القوة والإرادة
والقلب أيضًا من
خلال إحصائياتنا ، تمثل النساء حوالي
نصف الركاب في هذا الطابور الذين
ينتظرون عبور  عودة الحدود إلى
أوكرانيا
جلبت إيدينا أحفادها إلى بولندا
وهي عائدة الآن لتكون مع
عائلتها في أوديسا. ما مدى قلقك
على سلامتك.
لقد
أصبح الشعور مملًا بمرور الوقت ، أريد فقط أن أكون
بجوار عائلتي ،
هل تشعر أن هذه طريقة
للقتال من أجل
بلدك بالطبع تقول إننا جميعًا قد
توحدنا خلال هذا الوقت ، كل فرد يفعل
ما في وسعه لمساعدتنا  تقوم النساء العسكريين
بذلك والرجال أيضًا
يقفون مع العديد من النساء الذين التقينا بهم ماريا
هاليجان ، وستكون مع
زوجها وعائلتها للقتال في
كلماتها الإرهابيين الروس
إذا كنت تعرف ما عليك القيام به ،
فمن المستحيل
الشعور بالتوتر أو شيء من هذا القبيل  هذا
إذا كان علي القيام بذلك ، فسأفعل ذلك من أجل بلدي من
أجل أقاربي من أصدقائي
وما يميزني في هذا السطر
من الأشخاص الذين يعودون إلى أوكرانيا هو أن
هناك الكثير من النساء لماذا تعتقد
أنه
أنا؟  لست رجلاً لا أستطيع القتل ، أنا امرأة
وعملي
يحافظ على
التوازن ويساعدني
ويكون
لطيفًا ويهتم
بالأقارب والأصدقاء والعائلة وكل
الأنواع ، لكنني الآن أشعر أن جميع الأوكرانيين
أقاربي
قبل أن تغادر ماريا يظهرون لنا
قلبًا  العلم الأوكراني على شكل  منحها لها
الأطفال البولنديون لحمايتها
أولئك العائدين يمشون عبر
عربة تقرأ السلامة قبل كل شيء ،
لكن القطار الذي يغادر المنصة 5
يختفي
في منطقة حرب حيث الأمان هو حلم
إد لافينديرا سي إن شوماخر بولندا
أنت